okay how's everybody doing
um so here is here's here's the deal
right here is the the situation that we
are currently dealing with here um
Marvel Studios has decided not to live
stream d23 for reasons it makes sense to
nobody but themselves uh so the best we
have is Twitter and uh I will be keeping
you all company as we run over the
various bits of news that we get from
d23 here in about 30 minutes and uh I
will be making sense of all of it you
know because I have my theories and uh
what are my theories
what are my theories ever wrong oh man
next up is Marvel Studios if you aren't
already follow discussing film and turn
on notifications we are live tweeting
every piece of news yes okay Marvel
Studios
okay everybody relax stay calm stay calm
it's like that Meme from office
okay my performance of Rogers musical at
d23 they're doing a live performance of
the musical man get to the movie
announcements man
man
yeah exactly it's time it's time first
up is Black Panther wakanda forever okay
dude it was so cool to see that trailer
man there wasn't a dry eye in that whole
entire place when that trailer dropped
there was not a dry eye anywhere like it
was it was wild to see Ryan coogler says
he's still in the editing process and
Cutting Room for black panther wakanda
forever wow so he's still putting the
video together damn or the movie rather
I keep talking like he's a content
creator new footage from Black Panther
wakanda forever is being shown
exclusively at d23 damn it
Noah
oh
tweet out what's in the footage at the
very least
all right so the new footage for black
panther wakana forever is not being
released publicly it's only being shown
at d23 okay Expo footage uh for black
panther what kind of forever including a
shot a lot of name or action including
him fighting umbaku oh bro the name of
the Submariner
I am so down for that I am so down for
that are they gonna release footage for
ironheart exclusively for San Diego so
it's exclusive there like there's no
there's there's nothing oh Anthony Ramos
plays the hood and iron heart okay I'm
totally down for that right it's Parker
Robbins okay so that knocks out the fan
theories that were going on that uh
Donnie Blaze is playing the hood in the
MCU
so yeah he's playing Parker Robbins do
Parker Robin's man he's the Parker
Robbins is the guy that you just you you
love to root on you have to root him on
right you want to see him succeed but
like he never really does but he always
ends up in like just these huge schemes
like there's one where he got The
Infinity Gauntlet he assembled the whole
Infinity Gauntlet for himself like it
was it was crazy Ant-Man and was quantum
video
y'all know what that means man
yes okay Kane the Conqueror all right
what are they saying okay Amanda was
quantumania links directly with Avengers
the King Dynasty okay so one probably
segues into the other so I wouldn't be
surprised this movie basically ends with
the fact that they're like okay we have
to like assemble a team to stop king or
Loki meets up with Ant-Man
and just goes directly from there
directly lead to Avengers the King
Dynasty it's gonna be so good I am so
excited about that wow okay so
okay it's time to go back to discussing
Phil
oh
did you guys see it
oh man
[Laughter]
oh my goodness
all right let's update this let's update
this okay the Randall Park returns is
Jimmy woo and Ant-Man and was gone to me
I mean we kind of knew that already
didn't we like did we already know that
that was already confirmed in some
capacity right Paul Rudd says it's
unlike anything we've seen before all
right so it's just kind of them up there
talking
so that's cool uh werewolf by Knight has
officially announced badass all right
new footage of ant-manuel's quantumania
shown a d23
Scotland having to do a heist in the
quantum realm for Kang or else he won't
get Cassie back wow so King makes him do
a high I don't know how I feel about
that but we'll see we'll see yeah we'll
see how it goes all right werewolf by
nine I'm I'm really excited for Jack
Russell I'm really excited for werewolf
by night and yes that's the name of
werewolf59 it quite literally is Jack
Russell that's his name he was not it
was not a creative name at all he was
named after a dog
um I wonder what I was gonna I wonder
how that's gonna be
involved like who all is going to be a
part of that project
like I wonder if they're going to have
Moon night in there because technically
Moon Knight I originally appeared in a
werewolf By Night comic uh Michael
giacchino is officially revealed as the
director for werewolf by night he has
previously worked in the MCU as a
composer for scores including no way
home
um wait so they have a they have a
musician directing the film
that's interesting Gail Garcia Bernal
and Laura Donnelly are the leads of
werewolf by nine okay that's cool
honestly I'm not overly excited about
werewolf finite
um I'm not super hyped for that I mean
it'll be interesting to see but nothing
about werewolf why not gets me super
excited but it also depends on how they
handle it yeah this feels like a
throwback to like the old 70s horror
horror like movies and stuff like that
like this is gonna be awesome
yeah this is gonna be super cool
oh the first poster for werewolf by
night that's gonna be awesome
yeah the werewolf y9 is a black and
white retro horror mystery you know what
I'm totally down for that because that's
probably one of the only things that's
gonna make werewolf finite interesting
is to do it as kind of a retro throwback
oh secret invasion
okay secret Invasion and armor Wars I'm
so glad we're hearing something about
armor Wars okay for those of you guys
who don't know anything about that armor
Wars was a story back in the day where
basically I think Justin Hammer had paid
a guy to steal the tech of Tony Stark or
at least the ability to make Stark Tech
to make our Iron Man suits and then they
were sold by Justin Hammer I think to
virtually all these different people
um different villains so what you had
were a whole bunch of villains who were
running around with Tony Stark's armor
so if I'm a betting man because of the
way that the events of infinity war and
in-game ended I wouldn't be surprised if
armor Wars involves sheer uh um shuri
I'm sorry not sure um Ruby Williams in
some capacity but that people basically
stole Stark Tech and they're building
Iron Man suits as a result of that it
might even have callbacks to Iron Man 2.
yeah so that's not me that's that's
nothing new I don't know if it's new to
you guys I don't remember if they
released it publicly but we saw it as
San Diego I'm pretty sure
yeah first look at Olivia Coleman in
secret Invasion I'm willing to bet she's
uh she's not it's not slugert who's the
queen of the um slickert's one of the
goddesses clippin and slickert are the
gods and goddesses uh or the god and
goddess of the scroll race
um
I can't remember the name of the Queen
uh for yeah that's who it is thank you
thank you so much
I can I can never ever remember the
Queen's name yes thank you
uh Don Cheadle says armor Wars begins
filming next year and is set right after
secret Invasion okay so that's gonna be
interesting I wonder if I wonder how and
if they tie together okay so if it's set
to begin filming next year they don't
even have they won't even have a trailer
for it
um yeah it's just like it's a thing
we're working on so honestly I think the
reason why Don Cheadle is out talking
about armor Wars at the moment is so
that people don't forget about it
because some of the big question people
had is like what's going on with armor
Wars like is there anything about armor
Wars and like nobody was talking about
it people have just kind of forgotten
about it so okay so Loki season two see
okay so here's the thing is I understand
that the rumors were saying that Henry
Cavill is gonna play Hyperion in Loki
season two and I don't even know if
that's true enough I doubt it's true but
I don't know if that's true and I kind
of want it to be and then uh oh Loki's
on stage dude I bet dude I bet they have
a trailer for Loki season two it better
not be exclusive I'm gonna be pissed if
it is
I'm gonna be so mad if it is all the
trailers exclusive
oh no
oh yeah that is man thing and werewolf
By Night yep so that's so they're
burning right there so that's the idea
behind man thing so the way it works man
thing guards the uh guards the Florida
Everglades which honestly this might
even be a tie into that because man
thing guards the for uh the Florida
Everglades which is a which gives you
access to
um the Multiverse if you can pass
through it
um
the new official logo for armor Wars
okay that's cool
um
but yeah so those who know fear like
literally burn at the touch of the man
thing like you'll just set on fire and
you'll burn up it's one of the craziest
things nothing to say about Fantastic
Four
come on really
no uh okay Matt shackman is officially
directing the Fantastic Four but no
casting today okay that's fine see my
thought was if the rumors were true okay
I could see why they didn't do why they
wouldn't do that because the rumors
circulating around or that Dr Doom has a
post-credits scene in uh Black Panther
too if they marched the the guy out for
black for for Doctor Doom right the
actor for Dr Doom people will
immediately know that the post-credits
scene for black panther is correct
because they would they already have the
guy cast and they're like yep he's gonna
be the post-critic scene Vincent
d'onofio Returns His Kingpin and Echo
with a Band-Aid a bandage over his eye
that's the most Wilson Fisk thing ever
to get shot in the face and just cover
it with a bandage right to just kind of
be like yup that happens sometimes you
know and then just like walk away
footage for Loki season 2 included a lot
more King action and they had to make it
exclusive elusive bro no no uh
why
[Music]
uh
Daredevil born again okay
okay so dude I wonder I wonder if
they've got a trailer for it and it
better not be a freaking exclusive I'm
gonna be so pissed off at this exclusive
trailer okay dear double content
Daredevil stuff okay Daredevil stuff uh
new logo for Daredevil born again okay
that's awesome that's awesome that logo
looks cool oh it begins filming in 2023
with 18 episodes okay so they haven't
even started filming yet Charlie Cox
says he's excited to start filming I
started start again with Daredevil with
double the amount of time yeah I'm so
excited for that too I'm really I'm
really hyped about that too like I'm
really hyped about that too that's gonna
be amazing new logo for Captain America
New World Order okay so they're not
they're probably not going to show the
clip from Daredevil it's going to be
exclusive to d23
I'm excited for Captain America New
World Order
that's gonna be a pool that's gonna be
cool Tim Blake Nelson will return as the
leader in Captain America new world
order as the main villain oh perfect
perfect
he's a great villain to have pit against
Captain America
who would think it would be an
Incredible Hulk but not really
because because
they can introduce
so the intelligencia Marvel Comics were
basically just a group of the smartest
people the smartest villains in Marvel
so it was like a coming together of like
Modoc Doctor Doom
um the leader who else was part of the
intelligencia it wasn't I don't think it
was red skull in terms of like science
and technology he was an idiot but he
was really good when it came to military
strategy
um who were the leader who are the
members of the intelligence here guys uh
Carl lumbly will return as Isaiah
Bradley yes
oh my God yes okay weapons plus is gonna
be a part of this whole thing which if
it is it's becoming more I think it's
becoming I think
it's you it's actually coming to
fruition the more the more I look at
that the more it looks like the more it
looks like it is Jonas Ona describes
Captain America new world order as a
paranoid Thriller oh God that's gonna be
cool how in the hell is that even gonna
play out though
like how does that even play out okay
here we go Donnie Ramirez returns as the
new Falcon and Captain America New World
Order okay so Sam Wilson is staying
Captain America that makes sense but Sam
Wilson is like staying Captain America
he's getting his own Falcon now the cast
of The Thunderbolts minus pug
puke did say hi okay so is that hold on
is that Taskmaster
hold on this right here
so that I wonder if that's the actual
task master so that's that's my question
was Taskmaster the Taskmaster project
the one from like the the the
Whatchamacallit but this if it is man
this is cool man so we get Tony Masters
that's gonna be a great movie holy cow
that roster is legit which I'm so glad
you're seeing they're doing something
with ghost I'm so glad to see they're
doing that
okay huge care a huge cheers for
Sebastian Stan who joins a team of
thunderbolts as the Winter Soldier who
feige says is the most stable shoots
next year okay
it comes out next July
wait so Thunderbolts comes out in July
like July of 2023 or 2024 because they
haven't started shooting yet
I mean they better get on that they got
like a month or two
it shoots next year so I guess it comes
out 2024. all the Marvel's on stage oh I
wonder if they're gonna March out and
they're gonna be like actually there's a
member that we forgot to tell you guys
about and it's going to be like
it's it's going to be
Adam Brashear because that would be cool
but the Marvels dude I'm I'm so excited
for Marvel's I am so excited for that I
mean Brie Larson not so nobody cares
about Brie Larson but like everybody
else is gonna be awesome I'm really
excited for that that's gonna be cool
right after the post-credits scene of
Miss Marvel okay Monica Rambo is being
trained by Nick Fury damn you guys are
right like he's updating quick
Monica's suit looks great damn you guys
are right man the Marvel Studios panel
is over no uh so we got we didn't get
Deadpool we didn't get X-Men it's just
like updates to things we already know
about oh my God
so I wonder if they're going to save it
until San Diego of next year
if they're gonna if they're gonna do it
in the Hall of age of San Diego next
year
I wonder if that's what they're gonna do
it all right guys uh yeah so make sure
you guys hit uh make sure you guys hit
the like button make sure you guys uh
subscribe thank you guys for coming out
to the stream this was a blast but
that's the end of the Marvel Studios
panel I guess there's a box panel but
honestly we've been streaming for three
hours I think I'm kind of ready to call
it a day
um but yeah thanks for coming out guys
so we're gonna go ahead and wrap this up
we're gonna get to work on creating
content for you all we're getting to
work to creating content for you all and
uh yeah so
yeah make sure you guys hit the
Subscribe button and um we will catch
you all later
peace